In the last chapter we
developed sequential logic,
which contains both
combinational logic and memory
components.
The combinational logic
cloud is an acyclic graph
of components that obeys
the static discipline.
The static discipline guarantees
if we supply valid and stable
digital inputs, then we
will get valid and stable
digital outputs
by some specified
interval after the
last input transition.
There’s also a functional
specification that tells us
the output values for every
possible combination of input
values.
In this diagram, there are
k+m inputs and k+n outputs,
so the truth table for the
combinational logic will have
2^(k+m) rows and
k+n output columns.
The job of the
state registers is
to remember the current state
of the sequential logic.
The state is encoded as
some number k of bits,
which will allow us to
represent 2^k unique states.
Recall that the state
is used to capture,
in some appropriate way, the
relevant history of the input
sequence.
To the extent that previous
input values influence
the operation of the
sequential logic,
that happens through
the stored state bits.
Typically the LOAD input
of the state registers
is triggered by the rising edge
of a periodic signal, which
updates the stored state
with the new state calculated
by the combinational logic.
As designers we
have several tasks:
first we must decide
what output sequences
need to be generated in
response to the expected input
sequences.
A particular input may, in
fact, generate a long sequence
of output values.
Or the output may
remain unchanged
while the input sequence
is processed, step-by-step,
where the FSM is remembering
the relevant information
by updating its internal state.
Then we have to develop the
functional specification
for the logic so it
calculates the correct output
and next state values.
Finally, we need to come up
with an actual circuit diagram
for sequential logic system.
All the tasks are
pretty interesting,
so let’s get started!
As an example sequential system,
let’s make a combination lock.
The lock has a
1-bit input signal,
where the user enters
the combination
as a sequence of bits.
There’s one output
signal, UNLOCK,
which is 1 if and only if the
correct combination has been
entered.
In this example, we want
to assert UNLOCK, i.e.,
set UNLOCK to 1, when the
last four input values are
the sequence 0-1-1-0.
Mr. Blue is asking
a good question:
how many state bits do we need?
Do we have to remember
the last four input bits?
In which case, we’d
need four state bits.
Or can we remember
less information
and still do our job?
Aha!
We don’t need the complete
history of the last four
inputs, we only need to know
if the most recent entries
represent some part of a
partially-entered correct
combination.
In other words if the input
sequence doesn’t represent
a correct combination, we don’t
need to keep track of exactly
how it’s incorrect, we only
need to know that is incorrect.
With that observation in
mind, let’s figure out how
to represent the desired
behavior of our digital system.
We can characterize the behavior
of a sequential system using
a new abstraction called
a finite state machine,
or FSM for short.
The goal of the
FSM abstraction is
to describe the
input/output behavior
of the sequential
logic, independent
of its actual implementation.
A finite state machine has
a periodic CLOCK input.
A rising clock edge will
trigger the transition
from the current state
to the next state.
The FSM has a some
fixed number of states,
with a particular
state designated
as the initial or
starting state when
the FSM is first turned on.
One of the interesting
challenges in designing an FSM
is to determine the required
number of states since there’s
often a tradeoff between
the number of state bits
and the complexity of the
internal combinational logic
required to compute the
next state and outputs.
There are some number
of inputs, used
to convey all the
external information
necessary for the
FSM to do its job.
Again, there are interesting
design tradeoffs.
Suppose the FSM required
100 bits of input.
Should we have 100 inputs
and deliver the information
all at once?
Or should we have a single input
and deliver the information
as a 100-cycle sequence?
In many real world situations
where the sequential logic is
*much* faster than whatever
physical process we’re trying
to control,
we’ll often see the use
of bit-serial inputs where
the information arrives as a
sequence, one bit at a time.
That will allow us to use
much less signaling hardware,
at the cost of the time
required to transmit
the information sequentially.
The FSM has some number
outputs to convey the results
of the sequential
logic’s computations.
The comment before about
serial vs. parallel inputs
applies equally to choosing
how information should
be encoded on the outputs.
There are a set of
transition rules,
specifying how the
next state S-prime is
determined from the current
state S and the inputs I.
The specification
must be complete,
enumerating S-prime for
every possible combination
of S and I.
And, finally, there’s
the specification for how
the output values
should be determined.
The FSM design is
often a bit simpler
if the outputs are strictly a
function of the current state
S, but, in general,
the outputs can
be a function of both S
and the current inputs.
Now that we have our
abstraction in place,
let’s see how to use it to
design our combinational lock.